اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم جيش الاحتلال يعلن قتله بالخطا ثلاثه
محتجزين اسرائيليين في غزه وتحقيق اولي
يكشف ان القتلى كانوا يلوحون بالرايات
البيضاء وبان احدهم كان يستنجد باللغه
العبريه وعائلات المحتجزين تتظاهر احتجاجا
امام وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وتطالب
بصفقه تبادل فورا ونتنياهو يصف ما حدث
بالماسه الناطق باسم القسام يقول في تسجيل
حصلت عليه الجزيره ان القسام دمرت اكثر من
100 اليه اسرائيليه خلال خمسه ايام ويتحدث
عن استعانه جيش الاحتلال بمرتزقة
اعلام اسرائيليه تؤكد مقتل 20 جنديا في
معارك الشجاعيه خلال
اسبوع تشييع الزميل سامر ابو دقه مصور
قناه الجزيره بعد استشهاده اثر غاره
اسرائيليه استهدفته هو والزميل وائل
الدحدوح في خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه وشبكه
الجزيره تدين وتحمل اسرائيل مسؤوليه
استهداف العاملين مع الجزيره وعائلاتهم
بشكل ممنهج في حين تتواصل الغارات على
قطاع غزه حيث استشهد عشرات في قصف
الاحتلال منازل في جباليا وخان يونس جنوبي
قطاع
غزه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تواصل
اقتحام مدن وبلدات عده في الضفه الغربيه
اشتباكات بين مقاومين وقوات الاحتلال في
مخيم بلاطه في مدينه نابلس ومحاور عده في
المدينه ومواجهه بين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال اثناء اقتحامها مخيم شعفاط شمال
القدس الى
اللقاء